[Music]
thank you
hello to all our viewers we are
welcoming you back to a update that we
have for Clash of Mines but before we
start let's open with a word of prayer
let's do that Martin
I Heavenly Father
we want to thank you firstly that we can
be here once again we thank you for
health for
um support and everything that you do
for us and that
despite everything that happens in the
world you are still in control thank you
for that bless this episode this
discussion now in Jesus name amen
hello Walter hi Martin how are you doing
I'm doing very well and it seems like
you're doing also very well I'm back on
my feet yes
why not I'm actually sitting
no so we've you know that we've been
the world was flooded with messages of
you being very sick and in hospital in
ICU lung infections and all can you give
us an update
well I'm back so that's very uh good
news yes we went through a very
a bad patch there I don't know exactly
how it happened one day I was fine the
next day
everything broke loose
in fact we were on our ways to go and
get visas
when all of a sudden something went
seriously wrong and from one day to the
next I got quite sick and I did spend
time in hospital in and out
a total of 17 days and I was three days
in ICU
but the problem has been resolved there
were infections with antibiotic
resistant strains and
and it took a little bit of an
intervention here and an intervention
there but here I am yeah and by God's
grace uh I'm back on my feet I lost 15
kilograms in weight
but I've regained four well but I don't
want to regain 15. it's a good so yes
maybe you can take this opportunity to
thank all the viewers and everybody that
for their prayers and absolutely I mean
the response was overwhelming there was
a lot of information a lot of it was a
little bit behind the time and some of
it was not correct but be that as it may
I want to thank everyone that was
concerned and that prayed for me and it
it was really a miraculous experience
now thinking back on it
it wasn't easy but it served a purpose
and I think it it helped with many many
things
and uh I wasn't idle while I was in
hospital
in fact I held Evangelistic campaigns
from morning till night
attached to all kinds of equipment
and people wanted to know and I'll tell
the story but I think maybe maybe the
Lord wanted me to lion that ICU I was
longer in there than I should have been
I could have come out earlier yeah
but I think there was someone that had
to be reached and uh very interesting
stories and very interesting experiences
so it was evangelism of another sort not
the kind that I would cherish or want a
repetition or
but I'm feeling much much better and I
think we need to put the shoulder to the
wheel
and that was just an interlude yeah yes
and you so in the meantime yeah no uh
you were scheduled we mentioned it in a
previous times you were scheduled to be
in um Europe next month but but uh they
advised me I I shouldn't take a trip
like that until I am uh fully healed
inside which is still a process and I
shouldn't fly under those circumstances
so unfortunately that campaign has been
put on ice or has been yeah you your
presence has been my presence
campaign will still continue
but the ones that we've planned for
early next year or that are in the
pipeline for early next year they
certainly will take place according to
schedule if the Lord permits if the Lord
permits yes yeah in the meantime
um there's a lot of things that's been
going on here behind the camera that
we've had to attend to yes and we'll
update the viewers on some of these
projects yes and there are a lot of
questions and people are are very
confused about many things so let's try
and get rid of some of the confusions
and then also let us update you as to
what the plans are and what is happening
another thing that's very important to
us
we are so grateful to all the viewers
that you were so understanding in terms
of the short break that we took in order
to deal with all the side issues that
were taking place
that's number one and we also want to
thank our our contributors our donors
and our helpers thank you very much it
is it is so heartwarming to see how
people support us and how the ministry
is being furthered by many many ways of
which even we are not aware of God is
absolutely amazing and it's so great to
be part of this great end time movement
may it come to a close soon and may it
reach the crescendo of the loud cry and
by God's grace let us be part of it amen
so let's start off with uh some
confusion with some of the confusions in
the world out there
right one of the confusions that uh is
troubling many people is our
relationship with amazing discoveries
so the kind of questions that we get are
quite numerous
and people don't really understand how
all this fits in fits in yeah it works
when whenever we get a question or
anybody they don't they still like you
said confused and understand okay are
you part of Amazing Discoveries what is
the situation yes and then also amazing
discoveries was broadcasting to Africa
and then the Africa Channel disappeared
I don't know whether it's going to come
back or not I don't know what the status
quo is but this is the type of question
that we get Hello Clash of Mines I'm
somewhat confused are you still part of
amazing discoveries and if so have you
changed your position on the identity of
the King of the North and your stand on
biblical chronology it seems that there
are differences of opinion in the
ministry
this is the type of question we get and
many many times
and people are asking us you know what
is the relationship because obviously
Amazing Discoveries is still airing a
lot of material that emanates from my
past association with them
so let's try and answer that so that
people understand
let me also say right from the beginning
that we wish Amazing Discoveries well
and we hope that they prosper in their
Ministry because the more people there
are that spread their entire message the
better
but as for our position let's try and
answer it firstly
we are in no way affiliated with amazing
discoveries we are a totally separate
Ministry and have no influence on the
views which they hold or broadcast
so if their views differ from what we
have been saying we have no input
regarding that and where in fact we have
no contact virtually no contact
whatsoever
so I used to be associated with with ad
but since 2021 we have formed a separate
Ministry called Clash of Mines this is a
totally separate entity
and even though I'm still on the screens
yeah your your previous
um material and recordings that they did
with you
in previous years are still Aid on on
their channels that is fine by us that
is fine but Karen since 2021 actually
before that there's been no uh
recordings that you did with them or no
no nothing so everything that we do now
is through Clash of Mines Ministry so
amazing discoveries in North America
still distributes my older material an
amazing discoveries Germany has
permission to translate the what's up
Prof series
now people probably don't know that the
Amazing Discoveries Germany is also a
separate Ministry it has historic
connections but it is a totally
independent separate Ministry so amazing
discoveries Germany translates the
WhatsApp Prof series into German
but uh many ministries Yes translate our
work I don't know how many languages
we've got many languages I mean Under
The Clash of Minds you will find
different uh various language YouTube
channels yes wherein I've if I'm just
quickly thinking it as Serbian there's
Russian there's so many I think 11 or
more probably
um language languages that different
people translate yes the WhatsApp Prof
series our policy is we want to get the
Three Angels messages out into the world
and if a Ministry takes the trouble to
translate it and to broadcast it there
is nothing that we would want to do to
prevent something like that but if it's
in English then that's the prerogative
of clash of Mines to deal with that so
the episodes in German or other
Ministries
they are going out with our consent with
our permission yeah if there is
soliciting of funds through those
Ministries that is not from us we don't
solicit any funds no we don't solicit
funds we rely on the Holy Spirit to
impress minds and God has been very
gracious and thank you for your
responses
to that call
and then as far as the second part of
the question is concerned we have never
changed our position on the King of the
North being the papacy nor have we
backtracked on our discussions on
chronology since in our opinion the
evidence and the spirit of Prophecy is
clear enough to support our view that's
it so if if other Ministries have
different views that has got nothing to
do with us it's not with our input and
they're welcome to have different views
so that people can be led to study the
issues for themselves and come to their
own conclusion yeah because nobody
should be the guru for someone else
people must study for themselves
and to give incentives and ideas is part
of ministry that's it and we made our
position clear also in a few episodes of
what's up broth when it comes to our
view on where we are standing in the
Stream of time
we've made this view quite clear in
episode 8 is this the end and then we
add a part two because it created quite
a stir yeah but we haven't changed our
position yes and after that episode we
also got a lot of confirmation
in that we could put into episode nine
correct so that's our view on chronology
and where we're standing in the Stream
of time and we haven't changed that view
at all episode 106 Russia versus Ukraine
we had a lot of discussions on the king
of the north versus the King of the
South
and it's not not only in that and so we
spoke about the King of the North in
many many episodes and we have not
changed our position that the King of
the North according to our understanding
is the papacy correct
now Martin before we carry on with what
we are doing and what our plans are
WhatsApp Prof it's on the screen here on
the behind us
when are we going to start that up again
well we discussed it a little bit and we
think it would be interesting there's a
lot of things happening the first week
of October
so the ladau to see
2.0 will be coming out there's a warning
message that will be broadcast all over
the US on phones and TV and all of that
so maybe it's a good time to start our
fresh series again I hope you're not
sick
hey obviously the devil is going to
throw a lot of things at us so but let's
plan for that God willing will start in
the first week of October with what's up
Prof again and then we should be running
full steam with all the other projects
that we have in mind yes now maybe you
can tell them a little bit more yes
people want to know what are we doing
and how do we operate and why are we
doing things like we are doing we have a
we have a philosophy Martin
as you know
that it is of Paramount importance to
get the message out the Three Angels
messages must be broadcast like leaves
of autumn
we are aware that there will be
opposition we are aware that there will
be censorship and that is why we do not
want to rely only on the electronic
media in terms of the public domains
that we use like YouTube or any one of
them
because they might disappear or be
yeah yeah taken off there or because
they might be taken off the air or
something may happen so it's important
that people also have hard copies in
their hands yes we have at our disposal
now the electronic means and it's doing
well because it's spreading all over the
world we will use it as long as we are
able we will also try and get our own
channel we are also working on getting
an internet streaming Channel
so that we have our own servers involved
in in that yeah but we want to encourage
the people the people
get hard copies download we've got a
download server for free remember all
our downloads are free
even all our DVDs are free
and even our flash drives at this moment
are free as long as we can distribute
them in that way that's how long we will
do it because our intention is to get
the message out that's it and also it's
important that like-minded people start
putting together press together press
together yes that we can get this
message out and remember that
everybody is part of the team
because God is Not only using a Ministry
to get messages out he wants the people
to be involved and to help get it to
those that really need it because not
everybody has access so how are we
trying to get the message out let's have
a look at some of the ways in which we
do this
we have a distribution center in North
America it's The Clash of Mines U.S and
Canada distribution
and the people that are working there
for Clash of Mines are Ken and Lana and
we are very grateful to them because
they are doing a great job so if you
want to find out what Clash of Mines is
doing then please contact the office at
Clash of Minds North America and if
you're in North America so if anybody
wants to contact Clash of mines in North
America
then use the contact details on the
screen
here you can see them packing up those
boxes and sending them out
for free for free yeah I need the
postage and Martin this is made possible
because of the generous donations from
our donors yeah thank you thank you
thank you very much
then we also have Clash of Mines Europe
where Henry stoba is our representative
yeah Henry is a very enthusiastic person
as you know he's the one that does these
beautiful nature scenes and he is
responsible for the movies like The
Creation for example and much of our
material comes from him you'll remember
that we've broadcast quite a number of
uh the things that he has produced and
Barbara O'Neil for instance yes
and he has shot many series for us the
series by Barbara O'Neill for example
he's not done one by Walt cross he's
busy with other speakers so he's a very
very busy man and uh your donations also
make it possible to keep that work
rolling and Europe is a very very large
District
uh to control so he needs some help as
well
and this is the kind of thing that he
does he grabs a chair he puts it down in
nature and then there we go yeah and
make some nice devotionals with lots of
people have seen our shorts and the
video that goes out on the devotional
for Sabbath this is all Henry is doing
and uh I don't know what I would do
without Old Henry I I love his work I
think he he is such a charismatic person
and he always brings in he started the
adventure Prof you know so yeah people
already know him and we love him this is
a Henry setup in the field that's a solo
set up even having to record himself and
all of this this is in Iceland we would
have been there uh recording but
the Lord it didn't work out like this so
no I had to go and evangelize in the
hospital so but we'll see the Lord's
probably has some plans still so what
else do we do we have Clash of mind
field evangelists and let us show you
what Freddie and Patricia are doing
this is their van that we sponsor it's
got the Clash of mine sign on it over
there
and these people travel into all those
areas where no one else would go yeah
they travel into the different countries
they will travel to Zimbabwe they will
travel to Zambia at the moment they are
in Namibia
and they present the Three Angels
messages in the rural areas in the
heartlands in the bush where there is no
other way of of reaching these people
and we really want a whole tribe of
people that are willing to go into these
areas and spread the message
and there the fact that they are willing
to do this to travel and give up all
their home Comforts and do these things
is marvelous and this is one of the ways
in which Clash of Mines is sponsoring
evangelism so Martin when you think
about something like this we could hold
a whole series about how these things
come to be how you meet up with people
that are willing to do that well
how how the devil tries to prevent it
how their vehicles are confiscated how
they get them back again different ones
that are better suited for the job
the circumstances around these events
are just amazing the stories are
phenomenal
of every single one that's connected
with Clash of Minds it you have to have
your head red to be connected to Clash
of Mines being because every good deed
will be punished
yeah we've been at the brunt of that you
no matter what you do there will always
be opposition but didn't Spirit of
Prophecy say
they will never come a time when the
hell is Shadow Of Satan is not cost what
you part
and I want to assure you that even if
you're thinking you're going through
your darkest hour and I've just been
there let's be honest I I really felt
this was a very dark hour
the the Miracles that God does yeah and
the outcomes thereof are so amazing you
stand over order and all of these people
have amazing Stories it just looks so
romantic yeah yeah
there's a lot of mud involved
yeah they go
traveling through darkest Africa
presenting The Three Angels messages
and Freddie has had these things made
you blow them up so that you can cut
them around easily and then he gives
seminars on how you know the story of
Revelation sits and how it comes and now
that all Three Angels message fit into
this every great controversy and it
creates such interest and he sets it up
in in supermarkets he sets it up on
planes he says fares he sets it up in
the heartland of the rural areas next to
the chief's house and the people are
overroding he tells the story so here's
just one example where Freddie there he
is is working together with the West
Zambia conference
and it's a public Crusade and
we are so glad to be part of such
outreaches and then Martin let's tell
them the big story
we have managed to create another entity
which is called Verity Center
uh Verity is a nice name don't you think
no especially linked to the Three Angels
yes Verity means in truth right in truth
and uh in the spirit of Prophecy we read
that righteousness by faith is the third
Angel's message in Verity
and the third Angel's message is linked
to the right arm of the Gospel cannot be
saved cannot be establish otherwise you
have a crippled Angel right
and so the spirit of Prophecy tells us
that if you are involved in evangelism
then you are involved in medical
missionary work you cannot separate the
two the spirit of Prophecy says every
single member is a medical missionary
and so we decided that basically we have
marching orders
and so we created an entity called
Verity Center
where the right arm of the Gospel the
medical missionary work will form an
integral part of class of the Clash of
Minds ministry that's it so Verity
Center is that arm of clash of Mines
where medical missionary work becomes a
reality
and people will be able to be helped now
not only that it serves as a training
center
so at Verity we want to create a a
school of evangelism with a difference
the aim is to further the Three Angels
messages
to provide short courses not courses
over months and months and months but
short courses to empower people to
understand
how the Three Angels messages are linked
to the end time events what they must
achieve in this Fallen World and to
empower people to go out and to spread
the message yes to take the Three Angels
messages to the world to the people so
we are going to start probably
early next year maybe even at the end of
this year if possible
but we are getting there we want to
introduce these short courses and they
will be part of the Clash of Minds
program and whatever we do there we will
also broadcast it
so that it is available for the whole
world and not just for a few people
experiencing it everything all the
nitty-gritty is still being worked out
that's why we are so busy and why we're
taking the time to get everything in
order but yeah we will definitely have
uh broadcasting
um there will be also sermons and all
sorts of things coming out of there so
basically when we talk about the health
message it's the health message from the
ground up
from the ground up organic farming
from there to the table what is healthy
and what is not healthy how should the
lifestyle of someone living in these
lost days be how should it reflect what
the Bible and the spirit of Prophecy
teach us and then also the importance of
the Three Angels messages and this in a
nutshell in a package that can be done
in a relatively short time the details
will still be presented later
so this is what the Lord has enabled us
to to find it is a property where this
will take place and the Lord was good to
us amazing
there are so many miracles involved in
setting all of this up it is as though
there is something
driving us and the Lord is pushing and
saying hey it's telling us time is short
you better get on with it
so here we're trying to get some
irrigation into the ground
and it's a beautiful place
where we want to create this Ambiance
here was an old farmhouse that we
painted and renovated a little bit and
there were many many helpers that helped
us and we want to thank them all
so this is coming together
and here will be the Hub of the Bible
school or the school of evangelism and
the health center and the two must be
together because you cannot Savor the
right arm from the body that's it
the mutton
come a long way right yeah and it's been
set like there you can see it's set in a
beautiful setting the Lord's been
blessing us
um because along with the beautiful
creation
comes healing and also your thoughts can
go to your creator yeah that's part of
the first Angel's message now
one cannot imagine that this is even
possible
because this property was secured well
below market cost well below because the
original owner had a horse farm here and
it was too small for him and he moved
and it was basically abandoned and that
is why it was possible to get this piece
of land very close to where Clash of
Mines is situated and we think it is an
absolute
gift from heaven
so those are some of our plans
field evangelism
a bible school or a school of evangelism
a health center
and and distribution of the material
into people's hands that we can get this
Three Angels message and all of this
because look nothing that we've done in
the 171 episodes is severed from The
Three Angels message no everything is
part of the three Angelus message it's
always coming back to that and that is
what the world should know that is our
Focus
that is what we are doing
and the more we can do it the better
imagine if we can get whole teams
working imagine if we can evangelize not
only Africa but many parts of the world
how far will the imagination go how
powerful is God what can he do
let's work together
and let's all be part of a team
and made by the power of God the Three
Angels message be spread throughout the
entire region
you know the Bible and the spirit of
Prophecy are very very clear the Bible
says seek and you will find
the Bible also says few there are that
find it so Martin why don't they find it
because because they don't seek
so the prerequisite of finding is to
seek
but if people don't seek maybe they need
an incentive to want to seek
and this is where the Three Angels
messages comes in if you can give an
incentive so that people become
interested say what is going on here
yeah
and the message must be extraordinary it
can't be an ordinary message the world
is flooded with so much nonsense and
people's time is taken up by so much
rubbish that it takes an extraordinary
effort to get people to want to seek and
once they start seeking then they can
find
and God is more than capable and more
than able to provide much more than we
ever dreamed of look what he's doing
already for us it's amazing
so ask
and you shall receive that's a very very
important requisite but we ask so little
therefore we receive so little so let's
think big let's say to the Lord Lord I
don't want to reach a thousand people I
want to reach Millions no I'm not
satisfied with Millions I want to reach
billions we've got almost 8 billion
people in this world
not one less
that is our mission that is what we want
to do and we pray that you will be part
of the mission may God bless you all see
you soon and see you soon in the next
WhatsApp Prof thank you let's close with
prayer
Heavenly Father
all our circumstances that seem daunting
are your enablings
and we thank you for everything that you
have done for us and for Clash of Minds
and I pray Lord that much more will be
achieved
we have many thoughts and you have
blessed with many means in order to be
able to launch these programs
and I pray that there will be a fruit
but I pray that people will be involved
and feel part of it and that the message
may go out to the entire world
bless the viewers bless us bless the
message and may Millions stand on the
sea of glasses the consequences our
prayer in Jesus name amen amen
thank you
foreign